one of my favorites becky g
congratulations on your honor tonight
from variety how does it feel um
incredible um
i'm just truly like happy to be here
it's so weird i actually came to this
event um like almost
six years and some change ago when
sebastian and i first started dating and
we came together and i remember um
seeing the honorees of the night and
thinking wow it would be so cool to be
you know part of young hollywood making
a splash and like here we are it's so
cool yeah as long as i've known you
you've been making a splash my girl and
you did it in a major way at
lollapalooza we gotta talk about you and
j-hope on stage tell me about that
friendship oh it's amazing i mean he is
just like literally a walking cora
like he is the sweetest thing ever um
we're always like texting back and forth
like throughout like the months that go
by just to check in on each other but
obviously leading up to this our fans
had been waiting for a chicken noodle
soup performance for ages
and we were too in the amount of times
that we would try and it just wouldn't
line up and i always told him like you
call me i will always do my best to be
there
and um yeah some of my fans were shady
they're like of course she would pass up
he doesn't he doesn't know how important
this is to us and i'm like little do
y'all know i am backstage getting ready
i even tricked i tricked so many people
i had my sister send me a video uh from
the house of her watching it from the tv
and i posted it as if i was home like oh
my bro j-hope is killing it just
supporting me and two minutes later i
was on stage it was great oh my god what
did it feel like to perform in front of
all those fans the k-pop fans are so
passionate so passionate it was
incredible i truly enjoyed every single
second of it the preparation was um
it was interesting keeping it a surprise
like i told him you know i'm going to
rehearse send me videos because i
couldn't do sound check with him we
didn't want to spoil the surprise i flew
in the day in so like i didn't i just
walked onto stage and did what i had to
do
um but it's thanks to him you know he
was such a great host i i was so honored
to be invited i love that that
friendship between the two of you and
then we got to talk a little bit about
coachella you absolutely smash clochella
then you smash dodger stadium there's
nothing you can't do what is next on the
becky g bucket list um
well you know i think it's so weird to
think about this today because i feel
like people consume things so quickly
that you never feel like it's enough
like it's just never enough um there's
always something more to do there's
always somewhere else to be and i'm in a
season in my life now where i'm really
just like choosing myself and to be in
the moment you know like especially
after releasing a skimmer is like my
last album like i was like you know what
i love this album so much like at this
point i put it out whatever happens with
it it's for the world but like this is
mine and i'm going to take this in and
it's been really nice to just be like on
stages singing new songs singing songs
that fans want to sing um
and big performances you know like
lollapalooza like coachella like dodger
stadium you know i genuinely i took i
took the opportunity because i thought
no one was gonna stay
like no genuinely i was like it's it's a
late like it's a late post game thing i
think this is like a warm-up you know to
get the jitters out of like performing
your first show at dodger stadium and it
was so sweet like like a couple thousand
fans like stayed and it was so awesome
so you know l.a goes so hard for you
now i want to talk about something you
told variety in this issue i love you're
such a jlo fan and jayla was such a
becky fan oh yeah do you have your phone
on you i don't you said that you archive
every message that jlo sends you okay
why is it important to do that even
better of course like in your dms like
you don't like the the message is there
so like our dm conversation is a normal
dm conversation i don't like folder the
actual messages i think might be a
little silly but by chance my friends
have actually recorded me opening the
dms without me knowing and every single
time it's always this like emotional
reaction because you know i mean she she
gave me such a early blessing early on
in my career and i'm just so thankful
for that she's always been so lovely
with me and and um and so yeah like a dm
from jayla who wouldn't freak out like
that's that's the natural reaction
what's the sweetest thing she said to
you sweetest thing she said to me i mean
just that she's proud of me i think when
i saw her when she had done her
residency in vegas i brought my mom she
let me bring like all my cousins it was
awesome she was an amazing host um but
we hung out after the show and it was
just so funny she was looking and she's
like wow you've really grown up like
you're a big girl now so it's been cool
but you're always becky from the block
always thank you from the blog that's
right now i got to tell you the internet
went wild thinking about the fact that
dogia cat is in the shower video
[Music]
i'm thinking now it's 2022. you're both
superstars how do we get a collab a
proper collab between the two of you i'm
into it
the fans are into it doesn't if you're
into it we can get into it yeah like i'm
ready all day can i give you a quick
pitch please i want you and dojicat to
do a 2022 lady marmalade i love it would
you be down for that absolutely can we
can we flesh out the rest of the group
let's do it you dozia cat who else who
else
oh i mean you know it's funny when we
were at the billboards in vegas megan
was uh we were all like chatting and
stuff and that was like super cool so i
feel like megan could be in there for
sure i'm trying to think who else
normani my girl normani that would be
fire i feel like there's so many girls
now like i'm actually happy that this is
like where we are where like
i would almost i just want to invite
everyone and whoever wants to
participate is more than welcome to it's
a group
my final question you mentioned
sebastian earlier is he here tonight
he's not here tonight he actually just
made a big move to uh dallas fc yeah fc
dallas is his new team and so i'm a
part-time texan now yeah um i was joking
say i think i might have been from texas
in my past life so it almost like in a
weird way makes sense all of us who grew
up loving selena quintanilla
somehow right yeah but the fans have
been awesome and he's uh he's prepping
for a really big game so yeah i love
that you said that you're finally taking
the time to be like this is becky time
like i love watching the videos where
you're like cooking at home with
sebastian
are you guys you know still as much in
love as it seems like absolutely you
know it's um
it's a really beautiful thing when you
meet someone who grows
with you and individually and you guys
without even having to put any pressure
on it can just enjoy each other's
company
even when you're not together you know
right now we're navigating long
distances how do you make that work are
there any problems i mean we won't go
more than two weeks
yeah i don't know i mean we're kind of
used to it we're always so busy you know
so since the beginning it's kind of been
long distance even when we did live
together um so i don't know it just
works i i don't i don't know what the
secret sauce is and i don't know if i
could find like the words that would
really do it justice but i think where
we are right now is definitely like a
special chapter for sure do you think
about the next step is your family on
your back i know mine was my family's
been on my back since i came out the
womb what do you mean you come out the
woman mother you come out the woman wife
you come out the womb
you have to know how to do this you have
to know how to do that so like i'm
chilling i would be honest yes i mean i
wouldn't i know i'm not wasting my time
here of course
but um but i'm in me mode and he loves
it and i love that for me
you